haben sie denn als die ersten zahlen
nahe waren von ihren mitbewerbern die
erste nachricht geschickt
da mache ich keine unterschiede sondern
ich gratuliere allen demokratischen
parteien für einen wahlergebnisse und
ich freue mich aber vor allem erst mal
ich habe ehrlich gesagt die erste
nachricht an mein engstes umfeld
geschrieben weil ich mir erstmal freue
dass wir das erste mal in unserer
geschichte zweistellig in den deutschen
bundestag gewählt wurden nur von
überzeugungstätern weil dieser wahlkampf
die haben wir geführt ohne jede
koalitionsaussage und das ist ein echter
substanz gewinnt er mich sehr freut und
natürlich habe ich die hoffnung sie
wollen ja möglicherweise auch verhältnis
zu anderen parteien hinaus dass wir auch
eine regierung bilden können und prägen
können die unser land voranbringen
denn das haben wir dringend nötig in
deutschland na ja sehr wie schon gesagt
es ist ein sehr gutes ergebnis für die
fdp andererseits ihr lieblings
koalitionspartner union der wurde doch
abgestraft was bedeutet das für sie
jetzt für die nächsten tage ich habe
keine lieblings koalitionspartner
sondern ich habe inhaltlich überzeugung
daraus ergeben sich nähen und fern und
so haben wir ja diesen wahlkampf geführt
wir haben für konzepte geworben nicht
für koalitionen und für uns gilt nach
der wahl was wir vor der wahl gesagt
haben darauf müssen die bürgerinnen
bürger sich auch verlassen können das
heißt wir glauben wir müssen noch besser
werden bei den großen herausforderungen
wir müssen die rente endlich
zukunftssicher machen mit einem konzept
das auch langfristig funktioniert sind
klimaschutz besser machen durch
marktwirtschaft und innovation zur
digitalisierung gas geben das sind
unsere überzeugung und auf der basis
werden wir uns einbringen in den
nächsten tagen denn in deutschland waren
wir da in den letzten jahren nicht gut
genug und das muss sich ändern darum
geht es uns ist interessant dass sie
seine rente klima das wenn man aber über
die roten linien gesprochen hat von der
fdp dann ran ort steuersenkungen und
schuldengrenze
schuldenbremse nur im gespräch woran
liegt das naja wenn man es ja zwischen
zwei themen trennen einmal was sind die
herausforderungen und mit welchen
konzepten gehen wir sie an da haben wir
in diesem wahlkampf erlebt dass
teilweise wir überhaupt gar keine gehört
haben zum beispiel bei der rente wo wir
was vorgelegt haben da habe ich auch die
wettbewerber gewartet und das zweite ist
wie bewältigen wir diese herausforderung
mit welchen grundüberzeugung welchen
stärken und da glauben wir all die
herausforderungen gehen wir an durch die
kombination aus aufstiegsversprechen
chancengerechtigkeit durch bildung
offene gesellschaft und marktwirtschaft
und thum und soliden finanzen und daraus
ergeben sich die roten linien auf die
können die bürgerinnen bürger sich
verlassen denn wie gesagt nach der wahl
machen wir das was wir vor der wahl
gesagt haben es sieht so aus als würden
sie mit den grünen ja königsmacher
werden können wäre es nicht auch noch
option mit den grünen erst einmal zu
sprechen bevor man sich dann mit der
union oder mit der spd trifft ja erstmal
freue ich mich dass es stand jetzt wir
sind ja noch am anfang der hochrechnung
so aussieht als hätte rot grün rot keine
mehrheit im deutschen bundestag das
freut mich sehr dass war ein explizites
wahlziel da für mich persönlich den
letzten wochen viel geworben und das
womöglich vor der afg liegen und alles
andere ergibt sich in den nächsten tagen
heute warten wir jetzt erstmal das
endergebnis ab und freuen uns über ein
gutes ergebnis und die gespräche gibt
beginnen nicht heute johannes vogel
vielen dank